[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
happy nfl sunday everybody week 18. can
you get used to the sound of that and
yeah that's right greg clap it up we
made it man it's been fun you just
tapped into the vr betting squad rod
live in the bleacher report app
presented by draftkings and there's
something a little different about this
one we might have some new faces because
what's up new york welcome to having
mobile sports betting pretty fun isn't
it and we got something special planned
for the occasion in honor of sports
betting becoming legalized in the empire
state our friends over at draftkings are
offering a 50
free that's right free bet to any new
yorkers that sign up so i mean this last
week of the regular season what are you
waiting for get on there and do that and
if that isn't exciting enough for you
they're also boosting the no score for
first drive for all users for the giants
washington games later today so let's
get the starting party
party started started party all right
new york state it's great to have you on
the show but it's even better to have
you on the show greg how are we feeling
man i know we're uh we're kind of
jumping in the playoffs so we got to get
this regular season done
gotta get the regular season wrapped up
it's week 18 connor that feels kind of
weird to say but it's the new reality
it's week 18 feeling good new year
guess what same greg so i'm giving away
hoodies right now i'm in the comments
this right here is the handy dandy ipad
for the new people to the show if you
guys don't know now you know uh i see
mike ritter's in the comments shout out
to you mike ritter darren waller anytime
touchdown shout out to you noah goldberg
noah goldberg one says naji anytime
touchdown shout out to you and also
locks underwater winners only please
shout out to you all three of you for
walking away
what hoodies
connor greg is still in that giving food
yeah let's get it going greg is still in
the given mood i love that and you know
us right now we're always in that given
mood and that's why we ask you
for the anytime touchdown scorers of the
week we want to know who are the locks
to get in the end zone and these are the
featured choices that we received this
week deante johnson saquon barkley and
scary terry all at plus 150 over there
your boy greg dibo samuel just having a
monster here plus one sarah kind of like
those odds already aj brown then a
little bit up and down but when he gets
the targets he makes things happen dodgy
harris one of the best rookies in the
entire league mike evans a wide receiver
that is still playing over there for tom
brady at minus 120 and then jonathan
taylor basically on mars with those odds
at minus 300 don't want anything to do
with those so that being said
i don't think we waste any time greg we
got to find out who's going to be the
squad rod leader i know you got plenty
to give away today so tell them what's
in store
connor we're not only giving away
hoodies today we're also giving away two
nfl jerseys one to the winner of the
lock legend tournament and one to a
lucky commenter like yourself so don't
go anywhere stay tapped in stay right
here get in the comments give us your
takes we need gifts we need emojis but
most importantly we want winners only
please please please please
the man's asking nicely so let's get
into it winners only please
and we got our first contestant up that
we think can do that joe hossworth first
selection of the day in this wacky week
18. let's see the choice joe
so we have a monroe youth of detroit
young stud and devonta adams let's see
which one jersey picks
of course she chooses the sun god let's
go let's go with manor i'll lock it in
right now anytime touchdown score
all right amanra saint brown having a
phenomenal rookie season looking like a
draft steal for those rebuilding detroit
lions not bad odds here so the treat
legend going saint brown he's got a
worthy challenger a familiar face of the
show
and goldberg and i have a feeling he's
gonna have our old friend atlas with
them let's take a look
if he catches this frisbee
we're going to pick naji harris but if
he drops it we're going to pick aj brown
let's see what happens
oh look at that
good job atlas let's go najee
all right atlas making his return
showing some athleticism on the squad
right there naji harris coming in as the
selection what a catch there so greg you
got two rookies here matching up that
might be a squad ride first time uh
match up here for st brown and harris
and these teams man little different
story right now steelers are in
desperation mode there's no doubt about
that i want to send big van out on top
the lines in rebuilding mode they're
getting things going they're playing
hard and st brown's been a big part of
that reason let the people know what we
need for them to decide this matchup
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and let me know barack obama
saint brown or are we rocking with naji
harris
to move on to the next round
i'll jump in here connor i'm actually
torn i'm i'll be honest i'm torn we got
ammanra he scored four
he scored in four of his last five games
he's becoming the number one in detroit
connor he's making a statement out there
and i want you guys to hear me on this
one they're taking on green bay they
potentially will be playing their
backups green bay potentially have a
chance to be playing their backups so i
i kind of like this one for a mom bra uh
who's turning into that number one out
there in detroit but let's talk about
naji harris as well he's coming off the
big game connor he went for 22 for 1 188
in the last game he is that cowbell back
for the sinners we all know that
especially with big ben struggling right
now only throwing the ball two to five
yards down the field uh
i like this one i i i kind of like this
one it's a division game the ravens are
in and out on defense
but i'm just torn to make a decision
connor i'm torn to make a decision so
i'm going to lean on the people but
which way are you leaning connor
it's never a bad idea to lean on the
people they've guided us the right way
multiple times on this show and i'm with
you this is tough the monroe is hot at
the right time the matchup might be
extremely favorable for them and he
hasn't needed backup corners necessarily
this year so that's only an added bonus
but greg as we always say
lean on the players that are key pieces
and big games and the steelers right now
division game
this is their guide right the big ben
era is over honestly greg i think you
could push the ball vertically better
than big ben at this point and for that
that means it's a lot of check downs to
naji and run after the catch and a lot
of handoff so now she's gonna get that
workload we know baltimore's defense is
really beat up always trust big time
players in big time games so for me it's
close and i'm intrigued by saint brown
but i'm more comfortable with naji i
think he gets in the end zone today
where are the comments going
connor is comfortable with naji i'm
comfortable with the handy-dandy ipad
and giving away hoodies so let's talk to
the people
and see which way they are leaning
connor uh justin bodfield justin
bonfield says you see the towel greg he
has a terrible towel naji hair shout out
to you justin you are walking away with
the hoodie i want to win says i'll take
saint brown they will trail uh shout out
to you i want to win you are walking
away with a hoodie uh i'm back into the
comments connor i'm still here i got
trigger way says naji harris
naji harris
and uh i i i think in the comments naji
is taking it away so i'm gonna make a
decision comment uh connor shout out to
everybody that commented that's what i
meant to say shout out to everybody i
come to you are all walking away with a
hoodie but connor i'm making a decision
we are riding with naji harris
moving on to the next round and i'm
feeling good about that feeling good me
too greg's calling it the comments have
called it naji harris moving on round
two let's get into it we got a new
challenger i think ben merrick
entering the fold here ben is this gonna
be enough to knock off atlas and
goldberg let's take a look
the breakfast legend cooking up greg's
favorite adibo samuel omelet over there
on the skillet all right plus 120. you
gotta like that we said that at the top
of the show naji coming in at minus 105.
don't worry about that greg will flip
those odds upside down boosting the plus
money let's waste no time greg let's get
right into it this is a juicy matchup
right here and i'm not just saying that
because it's from the breakfast legend
juicy juicy juicy what i need everybody
to do is get in the comments and let me
know do you guys want to rock with debo
samuel or if you guys want to rock with
naji
harris let's jump right into it connor
uh i don't know if you saw the interview
of aaron donald this week but uh
he said that he knew who dibo samuel
samuels was because the whole rams know
who debo samuels is
my guy has been absolutely balling this
year he's taken on the rams who he
absolutely loves to play there's a
reason why aaron donald knows who he is
conor uh he scored in his last six of
his last seven games conor not only is
my guy catching the ball but he's also
running the football for the 49ers i
like those chances sitting at plus 120
you guys know what we can do here on the
squad ride so uh connor i actually like
i like the devo samuels play talk to me
do you like it do you love it maybe
maybe so
man i like it a lot i mean let's be real
and we're gonna see you know what the
rams bring forward today of course but
it doesn't really matter who he plays
he's been one of the rare match-up proof
players of this nfl season because when
teams take him away through the air they
put him in the backfield and hand him
the ball like you said greg so when you
look at that you love that it doesn't
matter what week it is how high stakes
the game are if it's starters or backups
or whatever it may be depot salmon or
who's playing quarterback trey lands
jimmy g hal shanahan your boys love to
keep that a mystery all week you can
rely on devo samuel and i think you can
rely on naji harris it's not to take
away from him at all this just comes
down to the odds for me i'm excited
about debo samuel here greg
does the audience share the same
feelings that's what we're wondering
right now
get into it and let's see
oh yeah the audience is riding with debo
i got big
big rail he got debo
doing a little flexing got him in a gift
shout out to you big rail uh your walk
away with hoodie seth uh m go blue is
doing the same thing shout out to you uh
i got
jrj93 tuck yo chain debo anytime
touchdowns winners only please please
say the police shout out to you jrj uh
you know the deal
everybody that i mentioned connor hold
on i got one more devo is doing
everything for san francisco winners
only please ben man 56 said that one uh
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with the hoodie connor this
one makes me happy because the devo
samuel sitting at plus 120
in a division game against the rams in a
must win game against the rams sitting
at plus 120 to score i love this one and
he is moving on to the next round
but he is not the squad ride leader just
yet greg so we got debo plus 120
beautiful odds final round okay and i
think we're gonna have to call up a
familiar face to challenge someone as
good as a devo samuel plus 120 pick so
numero the goat is back and he's got
something exciting for us this week
yeah shout out to br ben once again for
giving me the opportunity to do anytime
score for tomorrow for any time score
i'm gonna use my dog as a demonstration
whichever one whichever toy he picks
that's the anytime we'll be rocking with
tomorrow
we're rocking with that boy aj brown
anytime score tomorrow let's get it aj
brown minus 105. so
not the beauty of plus money but you
gotta love the pick when aj brown is the
target monster the focus of the offense
the guy gets things done greg i know you
love debo i also know you like aj brown
enough in that offense this is gonna be
tough man i think this might be another
one where we're leaning on the comments
to get us through the finish line uh
let's see what we got
yeah this one's gonna be tough what i
need you guys to do is get in the
comments and let me know if you guys are
rocking with bebo samuel or aj burrell
connor i'll jump in here uh i think that
this i like this one because of the
matchup i like this one because of the
matchup they're taking on the houston
texans no one fears the houston texan
but connor i i i strongly believe my guy
my guy ryan tannehill and aj brown is
starting to develop
uh uh some chemistry before the playoffs
a couple weeks ago he was feeding my guy
his first game back actually he was
feeding my guy aj brown against the
49ers uh and he had a really really good
game
derek henry i don't know if you saw
derek henry has been practicing connor
he's coming back
uh in the playoffs but i strongly feel
ryan tannehill is uh
starting to get this connection going
with aj brown at the right time right
before the playoffs so i i kind of like
this pic i i kind of like it but you
know where my heart lays you know where
my heart lays and it's plus 120 connor
but talk to me talk to me which one do
you like which way are you reading
well i already gave you the debo sales
pitch which i absolutely love if i got
to give an aj brown one and i have no
problem doing that you're all over it
greg when he came back two weeks ago he
had 16 targets and he caught 11 of them
so when they want him to be the focal
point he is the guy
beyond measures compared to almost
anybody else in football besides maybe a
cooper cup kind of player so when aj
brown is back he's healthy and they need
him
he's as true as a number one wide
receiver as you can find and like you
said derrick henry is coming back but
he's not back yet and sure you look at
the numbers last week against miami
they didn't really need him to do much
and miami's got maybe the best corner
duo in the entire league that didn't
even matter in that game you're 100
right about the matchup against houston
it's juicy i think he and they want to
clinch this number one seed that this is
the hardest week to figure out who's
going to play who's who's going to do
what who's going to rest they want to
clinch the number one seed
i like debo a lot i also like aj brown a
lot i am very curious where the comments
steer this one as we get to the finish
line for our final squad ride connor
let me hop into it let me hop into the
comments uh i got luis luis happy says
aj brown he's back he's healthy and he's
ready to cast that's why why for us for
the hoodie shout out to luis happy you
are walking away with a hoodie i got
dakin gams he got the devo gift from
friday the debo give shout out to you
deck and games you were also walking
away with a hoodie um here we go here we
go
if you like money greg lochen aj brown
don't sleep chewy ion chewie ion
just dropped that take uh aj is for
winners only i'm trying to find out who
said that oh it's mike mike m kent 93
connor
unfortunately
i got aj all day aj all day
aj all day from my guy m taylor 90 hold
on one more triggaway triggaway's back
trigger waves back all right all right
that's enough that that's enough because
it's it's aj brown is taking over the
comments and you guys know where my
heart is leaning but it's okay i am a
team player i am a squad
writer i i will ride with the squad any
day but it appears connor
the squad have chosen
aj brown to score a touchdown today so
let me show you guys something let me
show you guys something let's pull up
the graphics so i can show you guys the
magic that we do
here on the squad ride you guys see aj
brown sitting at -1 105 pouf there it is
thanks to our friends at draftkings for
boosting that up from minus 105 to plus
150 check out br betting socials for a
link to the odds boos send us your
screenshots of your bets send us your
videos and your celebrations we want
winners only
please
you truly love to see it the odds boost
the odds flip shout out to romero you're
taking home that jersey
gift card and the title squad ride
leader what more do you want all right
keeping moving we're still looking for
winners and we got the community comment
contest on and what better week to ask
you
which record are you betting on we got
the single season sack record on the
line and we got the regular season
receiving record on the line tj watt
going for the former cooper cup going
for the ladder greg what did the people
send you this week i want to know this
is a tough one i where are they going
ah well before we get into it i need you
guys to tell me which one you're right
away i'm going to send them a hoodie and
i might send you a hoodie for telling me
who i should ride with uh let's go to m
black 18 connor in black 18 says tj
got your boy tj watt
takes down the sack record today i mean
he's facing the ravens they have elusive
quarterbacks out there in baltimore
connor uh do you like this one
i do like this one and of course i worry
a little bit because of the rivalry here
does baltimore just completely try to
erase him and let anybody else beat him
does he get triple team today and what's
the guy that gets him in bunches he's
only played 14 games this year so for
anybody that thinks he needed the extra
game
you know that's not necessarily true he
has a chance to do this in a very normal
amount of games without the extra one
even less than that so i think he's got
a shot i like tyler huntley's escape
ability but baltimore they're just beat
up everywhere so i am a fan of this one
greg it would be really exciting if it
happens today and i think it does i
think watt's gonna play with even more
extra gear than we're used to seeing
which is hard to fathom
love that love that take carter uh let's
move on mike mojo 86 single season
reception and yards pretty sure he's
talking about my guy cooper cup connor
do you think this happens today taking
on the 49ers
i don't he needs 136 to top calvin
johnson i think that they won't put that
on cooper cup i think they want to get
into the postseason with everybody fresh
and healthy and ready to go and
i think right now you know besides the
fact stafford's been a little bit of a
roller coaster lately i think this would
require a lot of volume for cup in a
week where
i'm just not sure they necessarily need
it greg that's my biggest question now i
know you've got something to say though
because they're going to be seeing your
49ers
yeah connor uh
i'll be honest here i'll be honest here
this might be a curveball to some but i
can see this possibly happening
simply because the 49ers cornerbacks
they're struggling this year josh norman
just got benched last year they lead the
league in past past interferences uh
they're struggling that's their
kryptonite is cornerback so if matt
stafford wants to lean on his number one
receiver and find cooper cup i believe
there's gonna be openings for him to
find him against this niners defense now
am i saying the rams are gonna win no
i'm not saying that but
i can't see my guy cooper cup having a
day today let me get into these comments
connor let me get into these comments to
see
who we are giving away
hoodies to uh all right my boy larry
larry hall of fame says cooper cup
loading watch this easy money he had a
hundred plus almost every game i like
that larry i i do like that shout out to
my boy uh here we go i got
i got i want to win uh i like cooper cup
over tj more likely shout out to you
cup gets it done b-boy 22 cup gets it
done but falls short shout out to you
brother
that's it man that's it they all like
the cooper cup one but guess what
connor i'm gonna give both m black 18
and mike mojo 86 both of you guys are
walking away with hoodies it's week 18
man it's a week 18. yeah
given spirit unload the stock and let's
be real
both records might break today folks
honestly being real with you both of
them can be broken all right greg's in
the given mood and we're going to give
one more thing away both bets all right
last boldest bets of the regular season
greg let him know what we do here for
all the new new york users joining the
show
if you guys are new to the show
just make sure y'all let us know if
you're rocking with me or connor right
here we go y'all some bo bet y'all just
let us know if you rock with me or
connor connor let's get right to it man
tell them what your boat is that is
all right boldest bet of the week greg i
like getting a little different a little
creative we haven't done this one yet
it's called the under parlay okay we
might see some bad football out there on
the field today whether people are
resting whether people are hurt whether
quite frankly greg people want to go
home or they want to go play golf or
they want to be in cabo aka the giants
versus the washington football team the
packers versus the lions two very
different seasons and then the patriots
and the dolphins i just don't think
those quarterbacks are gonna do a lot
against the opposing secondaries so
we're going very low point totals for
plus 507. i i know there's always one
game that over scores i'm gonna be
honest with you i think this is gonna be
some ugly football this week where are
you going
connor i actually like this i actually
like this uh
i'm going with my guy from new england
man i'm going my guy from new england
and this one might this might surprise
some of you but my guy mac jones to
throw over two and a half passing
touchdowns they're facing the dolphins
you mentioned the dolphins cornerbacks
connors but fear not my guy bill
belichick
he's a guru he is a guru you guys saw
what the what the what the patriots did
last week what they did last week i
think mac jones is going to try to
continue this trend leading into the
playoffs everybody sees him as this game
manager this guy who's just handing the
ball off no no no no
my guy's going to come make a statement
as to why he should be rookie of the
year
this year so uh i think look for my guy
mac jones to be tossing some touchdowns
today and that's where i'm rocking it
all right greg tell him uh ask him who
are they riding with here i mean we got
to figure this thing out we always give
away
to anyone who's riding with me riding
with greg what do we got going on for
our finest final oldest bets
back into the handy dandy uh here we go
grumpy pineapple connor ivory money bets
shout out to you uh
he's not he's i guess he's riding with
both of us connor uh appreciate you i
got j will j will 86 right here greg
oh he says get some greg uh mac all the
way shout out to you brother uh here we
go
i i got
wow the comments are jumping as you guys
can see on the screen
here we go i got connor from isaac
bowman connor uh oh
connor jt 100 yards two plus cds
jacksonville was terrible and the coats
are playing for the playoff spot uh yeah
shout out to you isaac boatman uh your
walk away with hoodie connor i don't
know who they're choosing but it's okay
we're both winners we're both gonna ride
yeah so i mean pick his pick his bose
back pick mine so it doesn't matter
to everybody i mentioned you walk away
with hoodie
that's right and congratulations to the
squad ride contenders and the winner the
winner numero the goat the contenders
joe hosworth ben merrick and of course
our guy and goldberg with the best pup
atlas thank you for everyone in the
comment section especially shout out to
everyone that won a hoodie we are
betting is going to dm you within the
next 24 hours i would usually say right
now catch you same time same place next
week but we will be on saturday at 2 p.m
so we are back we're not going away for
the playoffs we're not resting greg and
i but we will catch you on saturday
afternoon so be with us then and join
the final regular season weekend
everybody have a good one
[Music]
so
[Music]
you